- Good morning Believe Nation.
Today's message is, follow your dreams.
Over to you, Chris Tucker.
(rooster crows)
(hip hop music)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
All that stuff I was just dreaming about,
this is the possibilities that can happen
if I move to California, or if you know.
Because I was working really hard here.
A lot of comedians come
down from LA and say,
"Man, you need to go to California,
'cause you pretty good."
I was getting a lot of good
advice, and a lot of people
who was really rooting for me.
Yeah, I just went and
did it, but I had a dream
and that dream gave me
confidence to keep going.
The power of believing
and dreaming is real.
Because that's all I did,
was dream and believe
that these things could happen,
and it make me feel good.
And that was my, that's true wealth.
If you believe, and
you're doing something.
You have a goal, you have
a dream to get somewhere.
It makes you feel good.
- This is something I think
is really, really, really
important for especially
entrepreneurs to understand.
In order for you to go out
and accomplish your dreams,
you're going to have to do some
things that will scare you.
You're going to have to push
outside your comfort zone.
You're going to be put
in pressure situations
that you've never been in before
and you're going to want to shrink back.
You're going to want to go down.
You're going to want to
retreat inside and say, "No."
To say, "I'm not ready, I'm not worthy.
"I can't do that. That's not me.
"I didn't go to school for that.
"I don't know how to do that.
"I've been told all my
life that I'm not able,
"I'm not capable. I don't
have the education."
On and on and on and on.
You'll find every logical
reason in the world
why you can't go out
and do that big thing.
You're going to come across multiple forks
in the road along your
journey, multiple milestones.
And you're going to want to shrink down.
And the thing that gives you
the courage to keep going,
to push through, to do that
scary thing, is your dream.
The thing that allows you to push through
all that craziness, all
that pain, awkwardness,
uncomfortableness, is the big picture.
Is what you want to go out and accomplish.
And that's why it's so
important that you have a dream
that really means something to you.
I look at what I've done with my
YouTube channel and helping entrepreneurs.
And I used to self sabotage, a lot.
I used to get speaking opportunities
and give myself a reason that
I can't go out and do that.
And I would say, "Oh, you know
my schedule's really busy."
Come up with some excuse, when really
I was just too afraid to do it.
I was too afraid to be on stage and
have thousands of people in the audience.
And have it on national television.
And have important people in
the room. I was too afraid.
And I would secretly hope that
people would cancel on me constantly.
And it's the dream of what I want to do.
It's the mission of helping
a billion entrepreneurs.
It allows me to do the
things that I'm scared to do.
It gives me the courage
to push through the pain,
and the fear, and the
uncomfortableness, to try.
If you want to do something big,
if you want to have an impact,
if you want to touch a
lot of people's lives,
you can't do it being the
person that you are right now.
You're going to have to grow.
You're going to have to build muscles that
you didn't know existed before.
You're going to have to test yourself.
It's going to happen.
There will be so many times
along your journey that
you will be tested.
And you will need to summon the courage
inside of yourself to push through.
And it comes from having
that big, bold dream
that you want to go and make
a big, important difference in the world.
And so the next time you're faced with
one of those uncomfortable challenges,
when you're being called to the
task, I hope you'll say yes.
I hope you'll follow your
dream, and not cow down.
So the question of the day today is
What was the hardest
thing you've had to do
to stay on path with your dream?
What's the biggest challenge,
the biggest obstacle
you've had to face so far,
and how have your dreams
helped you conquer it?
I'm curious to find out,
and I think it can also
serve as motivation for
other people watching.
Please leave it down in the comments below
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick shout out to
Tamyra Campbell, from Tam Cam Photo.
Thank you so much for picking
up 10 copies of my book.
It really, really, really means
a lot to me, and I appreciate it.
So, thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope
you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is.
Much love, and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
(hip hop music)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
So as a special bonus for you guys
to keep the energy high
on following your dreams,
I'm going to share a couple extra clips
that I hope you'll enjoy.
- It's one of my favorite quotes.
I came up with it, with my uncle
I had a uncle named Uncle Shrimp
- [Woman] Shrimp (laughs)
- Uncle Shrimp, he was
a short kind of guy.
Lost his hair at like the age
of 20, so he was bald-headed.
And he was just so charismatic.
And he told me this after I injured myself
and I realized that I wasn't
going to be a football player.
And he told me to never
lose sight of your dreams.
But he also told me this, as who I was.
He knew that now was going
to be a turning point.
Either I could return to the streets,
and follow in the footsteps of my father,
or I could dream the impossible dream.
- [Woman] Right
- He also wanted me to notice,
as an African American man
because, you know, that
fear of having a dream,
and that fear of, "Oh I can't dream that.
"I'll never be able to do that."
It was important to note that,
yes you can have that dream
but you have to know, honestly,
what it's going to take
for you to achieve that dream.
So then I came up with the quote
and it goes for everybody,
all genders, all races.
Don't be afraid to close
your eyes and dream,
but then you have to open
your eyes and see the reality
of what it's going to take
for you to achieve that dream.
And a lot of people, they kind of see
whether it's musicians, or
athletes, or entertainers
or even just successful people.
But they don't understand the
thing that it takes for them
to get to the point that they've gotten.
And that's why it's a very
important quote to me,
and I think it has inspired people.
And it inspires me every day.
- Was playing the guitar your real dream?
Your childhood dream?
- I tell you, a funny dream, kind of.
Because when I was about 11 years old,
I was in, I think seventh grade.
From grade one to six
you're in this one school
and then you go to this new school.
And I went to this new school,
and there was this girl.
This girl named Sandy.
She was so beautiful.
(woman laughs)
Big blue eyes, and this
perfect heart-shaped face.
And she was so, I was instantly
in love with this chick.
So the first day, I asked her like,
"You want to go steady with me?"
(laughter)
She was like, "Okay."
And so every day I'd
meet her at her locker,
and we'd kiss at the locker
and then she'd get on her bus
and I'd get on my bus and we'd go home
and talk on the phone all night.
And after seven days, she said, "You know,
"I'm new here, and
I just don't want to get tied down."
11 years old
(laughter)
"I don't want to get tied
into a relationship."
It absolutely broke my
heart. I was heartbroken.
And that night, I had a dream
that I was in a arena full of people
and I was playing guitar,
and it was this packed arena
and they're all going, "Yeah!"
And I'm playing, and I look down
and she's staring at me and
she's crying like (sobbing).
(laughter and applause)
That's true, and that--
- Revenge
- [Dave] Yeah
My rock and roll revenge
- [Host] We all--
- You could have been my girlfriend.
- We all have this dream,
but we just don't end up
in the Foo Fighters, that's the problem.
(laughter)
- Dreams come true.
- It's hard changing your life.
It was hard when just over three years ago
in the Penobscot Building
in Detroit, Michigan,
where I was operating my business
and I fell on some hard times
and I was sleeping in my office.
It was hard coming into the lobby,
and the security says,
"Excuse me, Mr. Brown.
"Can we see you for a moment?"
And I said, "Yes," and I
walked up to the counter
and he gave me an envelope, and he said,
"Would you mind reading it here?"
And I opened the envelope,
and the envelope was
from management that said,
"This is an office tower.
"It's not a hotel. Please do
not sleep in your office."
And I said, "Excuse me sir," I
said, "I just work long hours
"in creating my business.
I'm an entrepreneur.
"And right now things are bad for me.
"But they're not going
to be this way always."
And I just asked for the opportunity
to continue to operate like I'm doing.
I'm not trying to make this my home.
And it was hard coming through the lobby.
And sometimes they would laugh,
there's the guy talking
about becoming successful
and look at him, he's bathing
in the bathroom upstairs.
On the 21st floor, he sleeps on the floor.
Him and two other dreamers
up there, look at him.
It was hard, ladies and gentlemen,
coming to speak to people and I was facing
financial difficulties in my own life.
I was behind on my bills and my dreams,
and I'm saying to them,
"You can live your dream."
It was hard, ladies and gentlemen.
It was very difficult to
pick myself up each day
believing that I could do it.
There were times that I doubted myself.
I said, "God, why is
this happening to me?"
I'm just trying to take care
of my children and my mother.
I'm not trying to steal
or rob from anybody.
Why did this have to happen to me?
It was very hard, and here's
what I want to say to you,
for those of you that have
experienced some hardships,
don't give up on your dream.
No one could have
convinced me by holding on,
by continuing to push forward,
by continuing to run toward my dream,
that one day I would
have my own talk show.
It's a long shot, ladies and gentlemen.
From Liberty City, in an
abandoned building, on a floor,
never knowing my mother or
father, it's a long shot.
Being here with you today in this dome,
in Atlanta, it's a long shot.
No college training, labeled
educable mentally retarded.
But I kept running toward my dream.
(cheering from crowd)
Don't stop.
(cheering)
Don't stop running towards your dream.